I found a local physician willing to provide IV vitamin C infusions. We will begin after
I can provide them with a dosing and frequency. Can you throw out suggestions so I can get
started? Well, the physician who's giving you the IV infusions should be making this
suggestion. I will make you a suggestion, but they're the ones that are that they should
be the dosing doctors. I will tell you that most clinics that you go to for IV vitamin C
want to get you up to high doses very quickly. I think it's best to titrate, meaning that
you started a lower dose and you go up. Now, what dose do you start it? Something like
20 grams. And then over the course of a month, maybe you're getting up to 60, 80 grams.
That is also depends on how many times a week you're doing it. If you're just doing it
once a week, it might take you two months to get up to 80 grams or 75 grams. A lot of clinics
jump on 50 grams right away and get you up to 100 grams. It could have some side effects
too. So I don't know that personally, I would do that. I would start at 20 grams. Do that
multiple times and move up to 40 grams. It also depends on the bags that they're supplier
that they're getting them from and what increment, gram, increment that they can raise that
out. So, but I always think it's better to start slower and move up.